here's another problem that cortagio
sent me and like the other two this is
quite interesting although i think
you'll start to see a pattern forming in
how these are solved and that's the
whole point not just to show unique
problems but also to give you an
intuition of how to solve it so what
does it say it says alice is a hundred
meters from bill and bill is 300 meters
away from chelsea
maybe this is a bit of a clintonian
reference but who knows or maybe they
just wanted people with starting names a
b and c so let's let's draw that out so
alice is a hundred meters from bill
all right
alice is a hundred meters from bill and
actually he drew a little diagram so we
know that also chelsea is to the right
of bill so let's see it's the diagram he
sent me looks like this so you have
alice
and then you have 100 meters away you
have
bill
and then 300 meters to the right of that
you have chelsea
this distance
right here is 100 meters
and then this distance right there is
300 meters
and the problem tells us they all let's
see they are all facing east and are
standing on the same line fair enough so
let's say that's east so they're all
facing in that direction
standing in the same line they all
travel to the east at constant speeds
okay but they don't say that they're all
traveling at the same speed they all
they're each individual speed is
constant so this could be velocity of
alice
lower case a velocity of bill
and then this is the velocity of chelsea
all right they all travel to east at
constant speeds in six minutes alice
overtakes bill
so what has to happen let me do this in
another color and write down what that
equation would look like
so i'll do it in green in six minutes
alice overtakes bill
so what's the this tells us the distance
that alice travels in six minutes what's
the distance that alice travels in six
minutes it would be the velocity of
alice
times six
and she overtakes bill so that means she
goes 100 meters more than bill went well
bill
so that means she went 100 meters plus
the distance that bill went in that six
minutes and the distance that bill went
in six minutes is
velocity of bill
times
six
right this tells us in six minutes alice
went 100 meters more than however far
bill went in six minutes that's that
equation there we got it from this
information
and then the next thing this this
problem tells us in another
six minutes alice overtakes chelsea so
from the beginning of our time it
essentially takes 12 minutes right six
minutes to overtake bill and then
another six minutes to overtake chelsea
so 12 minutes to overtake chelsea so we
could write that as
the distance
that alice travels in 12 minutes is
equal to
well she has to overtake chelsea that
means she made up 400 meters of distance
so that she traveled 400 more meters
so the distance that alice travels is
going to be 400
meters more than the distance that
chelsea travels
in 12 minutes remember distance is just
equal to rate times time right so in 12
minutes is how far oh sorry this is how
far chelsea travels that's a c
and this is how far alice travels and
she's going to travel 400 meters more
okay that's what those two equations
tell us
and what is their question
they're asking us
how many minutes did it take
bill to overtake chelsea how many
minutes
did it take bill to overtake chelsea
all right so let's say this this
question we want to know time in minutes
time how long does it take bill to
overtake chelsea
so let's say we know that that it's time
t so that tells us that the velocity of
bill
the velocity of bill
times this time
is going to be equal to for him to
overtake chelsea he has to travel 300
meters more than her in that same amount
of time so he has to go 300 meters
more than how far chelsea travels in
that time so that's what this is and
then we essentially are just trying to
solve for this time we want to we want
to be able to solve for this let's solve
this equation
remember all of these equations really
have the same form in order for this
person to overtake this person in six
minutes that means in six minutes she
would have to travel 100 meters more
than him in 12 minutes she would have to
travel 400 meters more than chelsea and
then in t minutes and that's what we're
gonna have to solve the problem for b is
going to have to travel 300 meters more
than chelsea right there and we need to
solve for t so let's just solve for t so
do you get you get
v
b
t
minus v c t
is equal to 300 i just subtracted
chelsea's velocity times time from both
sides of this equation
we can factor out the time so let's do
that
so you get
v
b minus v c
times time right i just factoring out
the time is equal to 300
or time is equal to
300
over
vb
minus vc
so if we could somehow figure out what
this is equal to then we would have
solved our problem let's see if we can
use the other information so hopefully
let's see if we solve for vb here and
solve for vc here hopefully the va's
will cancel out and i suspect they will
otherwise this problem would not be
solvable so let's do that let's rewrite
this equation up here let's solve for vb
for bill's velocity
so if we take if we take
see if we divide both sides by
six well let's let's subtract 100 from
both sides so you have
bill's velocity times six that's just
that is equal to
six times alice's velocity minus 100 all
i did is i subtracted 100 from both
sides of this equation and i swapped the
sides divide both sides by six you get
the velocity of bill
is equal to
the velocity of alice
minus 100 over 6
100 over 6 or 50 over 3 i'll just keep
it as 100 over 6. fair enough
now see if we can do the same thing with
this equation so
we get
if we subtract 400 from both sides we
get 12 times
chelsea's velocity 12 times chelsea's
velocity
is equal to
12 times alice's velocity
minus 400
divide both sides of this equation by 12
you get chelsea's velocity is equal to
alice's velocity minus 400 over 12.
all right so let's see if we could
substitute this back in for vb
and subtract and substitute this back in
for vc and hopefully the va's cancel out
it already looks like they should
so our time
our time the time that it takes for bill
to overtake chelsea remember that's what
t was it's always good to remind
yourself what this whole problem was
about to begin with
is equal to 300
over vb well instead of vb let's write
let's write this va
va the velocity of alice minus 100 over
6
minus vc
so minus this right here
minus
va minus 400 over 12.
this should simplify to
t i'll just arbitrarily switch colors t
is equal to 300
over
va minus what's 100 over 6 100 over 6 is
the same thing as 50 over 3.
distribute the minus sign minus va we
can already see these are going to
cancel out minus times a minus plus 400
over 12 is the same thing as 200 over 6
or 100 over 3 right
plus 100 over 3.
these two cancel out va minus va
so then we're left with t is equal to
300
over 100 over 3 minus 50 over 3
right or i could say minus 50 over 3
plus 100 over 3. but either way minus 50
over 3 plus 100 over 3 is just 50 over
3.
right did i do that right if i divide
the top and the bottom by
4 i get this and then sure this is 100
over 3 and then 50 over 3. and so when
you divide by a fraction that's the same
thing as multiplying by its inverse 300
times
3 over 50
over 1 and then we can cancel out some
terms so we don't have to multiply big
numbers so if we divide the top and the
bottom by 50 that becomes 1 this becomes
six
and then we're left with t
is equal to
six times three over one which is
eighteen and all the time units we were
working with the whole time were in
minutes and we're done that was a little
hairier than the other two but notice we
were able to solve it by just
algebraically writing down the
information that they actually gave us
in the problem and just seeing what we
had to solve for and then substituting
back in and then miraculously
things canceled out and in general if
you're given a nice problem like this
you can normally just you know
march forward knowing that if you do
things correctly probably nice things
will happen and terms will cancel out
but i thought you would find that
interesting and once again thanks to
cortaggio for that problem